While in development,
Service Workers can be a bit of
a pain to work with it first.
So let me show you a few tips and
tricks.
Generally, I work in
an incognito window.
That way, I can be sure that each
time I close and reopen the window,
the Service Worker and anything stored
in the cache has been blown away and
I'm starting fresh.
Chrome://serviceworker-internals is
a super helpful tool.
It'll show you all of the installed
Service Workers, their state,
allow you to update them or
get rid of them.
The open DevTools window and pause
JavaScript execution on Service Worker
start up for debugging is helpful if
you need to debug the install event or,
code that's run when
the Service Worker first wakes up.
But be careful with it,
if you have multiple sites with
Service Workers installed it'll open for
every site, which can be a pain
when you're debugging one site.
When you open a page
that has a Service Worker
the browser spins up
that Service Worker.
Then if you open another page that falls
within the scope of that Service Worker,
the browser doesn't spin up another
Service Worker it uses the same one.
That means if you have multiple tabs or
windows open there's
only one Service Worker.
But what happens when you
update the Service Worker?
The new Service Worker sits idle waiting
until all of the windows that used
the previous Service Worker have closed.
Check out the skip waiting and
client's claim for a way to avoid this.
In addition to the Service Workers
internal page,
you can also use the Resources tab
in the Chrome DevTools to see what's
going on with your Service Worker.
It also gives you access to the cache.
So you can verify everything
was cached properly.
Finally, if you didn't use
an incognito window and
you want to get rid of everything,
you can use,
chrome//settings/cookies and
remove everything there.